I think it's also
always important for marketing that I turn around and
say where do I come from and what
exactly is it? We want to
remain unique, we're not interchangeable
and I think that's a huge advantage.
What do I know if I have another one?
I have skin cream or something like that, it's not
comparable and I think that's
really a gift, but it's clear
that the SAS is special now for someone
in Brazil or someone in the USA who does
n't have a salary yet, they
're also paid in and or  I'll say we
'll go there too, so I'll say
after October to Blumenau in
Brazil I'll of course go there
with voxclub or really, of course,
I was at Wacken too but I want
a
noodle like that